I shade black here for Fandango movie
clips with things that you might want to
know before you go into theaters to see
the nice guy the nice guys is
essentially a film noir I think that the
fun of this is it's sold as a comedy
there's a lot of fun to be had a lot of
jokes but I think there's a heart to it
I think the bumbling miss of Ryan is
interesting because normally I would do
the Lethal Weapon version where it's a
tough guy who's just better than
everyone at doing what he does these
guys aren't really that good they have a
spark of something that by the end
they're gonna have to find but along the
way they're kind of you know there's not
much they do right Ryan is great with
that he's great with physical comedy
Ryan would fling himself back and forth
in this movie and there was even one
scene where he won to go through some
plate-glass he said you're the star dude
if you break your arm we're done I'm not
gonna break my arm if you watch the
scene he falls back to a plane a glass
and that's him and the fact that an
actor just wants to fling himself
headlong as these stunts is both
terrifying and gratifying because both
the actors Russell and Ryan got the film
I think you'll be pleasantly surprised
at how funny these guys are that you may
have known predominantly through their
more heavy sort of serious work and
think those are dramatic actors and
thinking about putting your nice ties
together with my partner my writing
partner Anthony Bagga Rosie look into
the 50s and 60s and look at the cover
art by Robert McGuinness because these
kinds of artwork where some of the
template that we used in preparing the
nice guys this pulp paperback cover art
half-clad lady would perch with a gun in
a superior position by the way leaning
on a desk with a guy on the ground with
his tie askew smoking a cigarette all of
this sort of ultra noir very masculine
very sexy imagery and I love doing this
because I can make detective stories for
the rest of my life in fact even if I'm
doing a movie about 1/8 half foot tall
monster called the predator there's
going to be a detective story probably
somewhere inside it there was that one
day when I had some bad chili at lunch
and I stumbled back to my trailer and
I'm in that little cubicle and and I'm
hearing Ryan Gosling I'm hearing ababa
blah but what I don't know is I in
Ryan's trailer so basically you know
taking a dump in Ryan's trailer
looks just like mine so he opens the
door and I'm just hello and that was
kind of embarrassing so for my birthday
two weeks later he got me a big toilet
seat which I were around my neck while I
filmed now that is potentially
embarrassing so what I'm gonna ask you
is don't tell anybody that story just
keep it to yourself that's not something
I want to show hey thanks thanks for
coming I'm watching movie clips things
to know before you go see the nice guy
on May 20th
that's the date to remember go see the
nice guys who do doesn't love a good
detective picture see it or I'll find
you I won't hurt you I'll just find you
and gently you know say you might want
to go see the movie
you